près de clermont ferrand donc un jeune
homme qui roulait à moto a été tué par
la foudre et son passager a été blessé
ce n'est malheureusement pas la première
fois cet été et patrice pelé a cherché à
savoir à la fois ce qu'il fallait faire
pour se protéger et surtout pour
comprendre ce phénomène de la foudre
être touché par la foudre
c'est recevoir l'équivalent de 500 mille
volts en moins d'une seconde
rien ni personne ne résiste à cette
décharge atmosphérique hier dans la
région de clermont-ferrand
un motard est mort foudroyé parce qu'il
circulait sur une route déserte sous 1
euro
dans ce laboratoire d'électricité de
france en étudie depuis plusieurs années
la foudre pour déterminer son point
d'impact
résultat tout semble montrer que c'est
l'objet le plus haut est
géographiquement le plus isolé qui sert
de transfert entre le sol et le nuage
chargé d'électricité
n'est clair c'est une décharge
électrique donc soit entre deux nuages
dues à la différence de potentiel entre
deux nuages soit entre le nuage et le et
la terre et on parle de foudre
uniquement dans le cas donc de décharge
électrique entre le nuage et la terre
entre le 26 juillet et aujourd'hui
quatre personnes sont mortes en france
foudroyé pendant un orage pour éviter la
foudre
pas grand chose à faire à part
s'allonger sur le sol ou se promener
avec un paratonnerre
seule la voiture et l'avion grâce à leur
charpente métallique représentait
jusqu'à présent un bon isolant
mais les choses changent car
l'apparition du plastique pour les
voitures et des matériaux composites
pour l'aviation risque d2d à l'avenir
quelques sueurs froides à certains
passagers